c'est une première depuis 1998
l'examen du code de la route va faire
peau neuve présenté il ya quelques mois
par le ministère de l'intérieur la
réforme prévoit de passer de 700 à 1000
questions mais surtout de réduire les
délais du passage du permis en
privatisant l'examen du code on améliore
la qualité ont diminué délais et les
candidats sont fait satisfait ça ne ça
ne pénalise pas les inspecteurs en place
en dévalorisant leurs actions et et nous
les directeurs d'écoles de conduite
entretenons des relations plus apaisées
avec nos candidats boîte automatique et
nouvelles technologies les questions se
veulent plus moderne le remplacement des
anciennes question est prévue pour le 18
avril bien trop tôt selon le conseil
national des professions de l'automobile
lundi 29 février le syndicat a appelé
les auto-écoles à manifester dans la rue
elles étaient près de 1000 dans la
capitale que direz tant j'ai deux mois
avant le bac on changeait de l'épreuve
on est fiers de nos élèves on est fiers
de leur forme à turin et on les défend
at il faut avoir un bus de plus et pour
ta demandons que cette réforme est une
réforme nécessaire et obligatoire je le
répète lui débuter en septembre
selon le cnp a il faut en moyenne quatre
mois pour former un candidat au code de
la route
mais sur cette mobilisation le principal
syndicat de la profession fait cavalier
seul les organisations unique et une
idex sont félicités de cette réforme et
n'ont pas pris part à la manifestation